la amazonía colombiana en llamas enero
se convirtió en el mes con mayores
puntos de calor en la última década el
80 se trata de incendios forestales el
fuego afecta a la biodiversidad y los
numerosos parques naturales en el
corredor ecológico en la unión entre los
andes y el amazonas hemos declarado
alerta roja en el guaviare debido al
incremento de incendios forestales que
ya consumen más de 10 mil hectáreas
afectando cultivos de pancoger flora y
fauna con la época seca se incrementa la
deforestación del monte para ampliar la
frontera agropecuaria que permite el
acaparamiento de tierras que se
consolida con los proyectos de ganadería
pero también para los cultivos de uso
ilícito en una región con amplias
plantaciones de coca
sandra vilar con france24 sobre
ello las acciones criminales del poder
económico y político que hay detrás de
esas de estar magnitud del trabajo que
implica llegar a estas zonas boscosas
para talar y quemar se está se está
viendo desbordada las acciones del
gobierno colombiano el gobierno nacional
continúa con su operación artemisa para
frenar la deforestación con la ayuda del
ejército que ha incrementado también las
tensiones entre los militares los
campesinos que denuncian hostigamientos
de artemisa lamentablemente no está
logrado estar detrás de los
determinadores de estas acciones
criminales y está muy asociado el tema
no solamente de aprovechamiento forestal
sino también de ganadería y otros
cultivos más legales según las
autoridades colombianas el humo derivado
de estos incendios podría empeorar la
calidad del aire de bogotá la capital y
otras ciudades del país además sus
consecuencias repercutirán gravemente a
la crisis climática